[Music]
hi everyone in this video i'll be
showing you some clips from the 2018
annual aikido seminar in saint
petersburg
i've taken some extracts from throughout
the week and grouped them together based
on themes
i'll list them in the description below
tony sergeant sensei took the majority
of their classes
however there are also some russian
senseis teaching that week
whilst i was there i was tested for my
second dan and i was also kindly invited
to teach
rad shawn also flew out to join us from
the uk you may have seen him in some of
my previous sparring videos towards the
end of the week we also took some time
out to go look around some petersburg
and visit some museums
anyway i hope you enjoyed the video as
always please like share and subscribe
and ask any questions in the comments
below
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
you're missing that please
the hard thing is a lot of people they
pull out too far and they try to push
down
it will pass down
[Applause]
i
so
[Music]
she sees the rest
so we're both working here together
once we both now know
how to uh escape from each other
that doesn't work so we have to then
come up with something else
[Music]
we must finish
more advanced people
[Music]
is
again most people they like the kentai
joe
um
[Music]
i see a lot of people they do this and
they enter it
you can't do that on this one
uh
is
[Music]
a point
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and you're pressing him down but he's
imagining so
it will feel a little strange
[Music]
do something with this
but when you have the space
foreign
[Applause]
hey
but on this one sometimes
you might just go down
down before
and you notice that i'm here because i
might need to get out very fast
lots of carry-ons
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
um
[Music]
hey
um
[Music]
is
what
[Music]
me
with us
exhibit will cultivate
[Music]
this is where i'm driving my camera
is
[Music]
uh
you've been doing all this
is
if i had a piece of joe
connected
[Applause]
[Music]
has no um
it has no
[Applause]
them against things i'm going to go
around this this is going to become the
[Music]
center
this is the uh
hey
[Music]
is
i've been really bad at keeping keeping
up to date with filming
uh regularly but what can you do
um yeah so we're taking the day off
today
uh raj united a few others are gonna go
on to
just check out some petersburg they're
gonna show us around
um they'll just take a break because
it's been pretty intensive week
[Music]
now
so the day off was actually quite full
on we walked all around saint petersburg
and visited the hermitage museum
this place was huge and it would be
impossible to see everything in it so we
had to decide on which areas we wanted
to see
naturally we were drawn to the armory
section so we spent several hours there
looking at swords and other weapons
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow i'm going to be leaving in the
evening um
and i'll be heading straight off to
tallinn um
because i'm leaving in the evening i'm
thinking i might have to just stop along
the way somewhere just have a bit of a
rest
um i don't know how long it's going to
take at the border as well
when i'm leaving i don't know if there's
going to be any issues um
but we'll see i guess so um yeah so
we've got another
uh well i've got another two days of
training um
uh luchadeshi's carrying on um until
monday they finish on monday um but i
will be here for monday
but still should be good um
i'm fairly i'm i'm starting to feel it
now so
i think after this weekend i think i'll
be done um
well these guys are like machines so i'm
sure they'll just uh
carry on through so um yeah so i'll uh
you in a bit it's not being asked to
teach today um
looking forward to it uh i hope it goes
well
i'll let you know what happens so this
is the first class that i've taught
where i've needed a translator
i found it pretty challenging but i got
used to it and it seemed to manage okay
i taught a room in aggie focusing
particularly on ura movements
the feedback that i got was really
positive so i was pretty happy about
that
if you're interested in seeing the
details of this class i've actually
uploaded
it as a separate video so i'll leave a
link in the description below
if anyone's serious about training in
aikido i'll definitely recommend
traveling there sometime as there's some
excellent teachers
i'll leave all their details in the
description below
again i'd like to thank them all for
everything they did for me whilst i was
there
and also allowing me to film so before
leaving the dojo
i joined the group for a pizza party
which was a really nice way to end the
week
everyone's really hospitable and a great
group to train with
i'll definitely be planning future trips
there again sometime soon
now i've got the exciting job of packing
the car and
getting ready to go
next stop is going to be estonia
so last night was um they asked me to do
a bit of a fire show for him
uh down at the park it's quite good
although it just meant that
yesterday
[Music]
anyway it's all good
continue straight so i'm hoping to get
to the border
with the estonian border at about
half seven it's now about five o'clock
see how that goes the roads are pretty
empty
which is good um i was just hoping i was
gonna miss any sort of traffic
so
hopefully they'll start quite empty i
just need to fill up and find a
petrol station somewhere hopefully one
on the road
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you